hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the
monday morning podcast
for monday
uh february 28 2022
[Music]
22
what's going on
how are you
oh people i got a [ __ ] earworm i i
listened to this song the other day and
i i cannot
i cannot get it out of my head
because phil collins plays on the track
and he [ __ ] kills it
um
it was something my drum teacher told me
about
a couple years ago and for some i don't
know i was on the internet
just going down the [ __ ] rabbit hole
and i found that song again and i
listened to it and i cannot get the
[ __ ] song out of my head and i'm
warning you right now
that if you go
and you listen to this song you are
going to be in the same place that i am
okay so you know that going in
okay
i've let you so this you cannot sue the
podcast
if you can't get this
[ __ ] song out of your goddamn head
for the last four days
five days maybe
i have had tears for fears
a woman in chains
in my head
you know
i just can't get it out of and i don't
even know
i don't even know the words
i just love phil collins drummond on it
it starts off i don't know what you say
you better
it's like
the ultimate
you know
women can do no wrong
at no point in the song do they ask why
the guy had to put his woman in chains
you know
maybe she was lighting up the credit
card tears for fears right did they ever
think of that nope
metastone
right it's all about how men are [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um
and at one point this woman
listened to this song like 400 [ __ ]
times
because phil collins kills it so hard on
the track
and i still have no idea what any of the
words are other than metastone
[Laughter]
then it always makes me laugh when he
screams it
um are we stoned
is that what we are we just sort of
beaten down and we don't have any
[ __ ] fight left in us
um now jesus bill are you going to start
this way is this how you're going to
start the podcast
um yeah i am
so
free
then that's how it goes it goes into
that listen i'm not saying they don't
have a valid argument you know
i'm not saying that there hasn't been
times
you know
that you know as a man
you're going into a store and you don't
want to bring your woman in so you know
you tell her to stay in the car
and you leave her in there like a
[ __ ] dog
and then they start crying
and then they put that song on i think
that's what that's what happens
you better not leave me here
you better not leave me here
woman in cars
just
stay in the car why why can't i go in
because you're gonna want you're gonna
want something
you know it's like a kid i can't bring a
kid in there and then they're gonna see
a [ __ ] toy and then i gotta deal with
that
and both of you are gonna end up in
tears
all right
then you're gonna start telling me how
i'm [ __ ] cold and then put on
medicine
uh but listen to phil collins on that
you know people there's still like a
question was was phil collins really a
great drummer was he really
was he really a great drummer
you know because all they think of was
when he did like uh
well did he just sing i'm walking on
sunshine he had like all those [ __ ]
so studio all those songs but listen to
brandex and listen to all this the [ __ ]
he did with robert plant
incredible i i want to hear from ginger
baker uh fans though
you know when uh i was always i'll
always be blown away how
when i watched that uh beware mr baker
the way eric clapton
dismissed the argument that john bonham
was anywhere near
as good a drummer
as ginger baker
they asked him and he just goes oh no
they're not even in the same
conversation
and i was like i don't know what the
[ __ ]
i've been doing i got to go back and
listen to cream which i did
and it wasn't until i saw ginger baker's
like
the drum solo he did it like royal
albert hall i don't know if i've talked
about this before i have no idea people
i've been having problems sleeping
lately i've been stressed out getting
ready to do this [ __ ] project
you know and there's only so many nights
you can do a [ __ ] you know john wayne
double shot of [ __ ] nyquil before you
just have to address the fact
that you're gonna have to start counting
sheep right
um
anyway
yeah i just could not [ __ ] sleep last
night i was just
laying in [ __ ] bed you know like when
you're so tired you're like i need to go
to sleep i need to go to sleep and then
your brain
is just going going going going going
and i'm like all right it's midnight
all right it's one in the morning oh
it's gotta be like a quarter to two
it's gotta be a quarter to two and then
you [ __ ] wake up at like 5 45 a.m
because you're thinking about all this
[ __ ] you have to do today
you know doesn't this sound like the
beginning of the in an infomercial and
i'm gonna have a solution for this at
the end of it
start eating grapefruit do you know
anybody remember that remember the
grapefruit 45 diet i don't know anybody
who eats grapefruit or doesn't lose
weight
the problem is you'd have to eat 80
grapefruits a day
to [ __ ] lose your man tits
but now we've glued this construction
worker to a [ __ ]
steel girder whatever all those things
were the same
i miss those guys screaming at me
the end of an era was when that billy
mays died ah billy mays look at this
vacuum cleaner
you better get your kids out of the room
it'll [ __ ] suck them up too
screaming and then there was that other
guy who had the exercise equipment and
he was jacked
anybody was dressed like he was going to
go scuba diving remember that was that
was like a that was a look for a while
he dressed that way the drummer for uh
dave matthews band used to dress that
way
they all dressed like at any moment
like they were gonna go [ __ ] jump on
a boogie board
and they walked around in public some of
them performed concerts in front of
[ __ ]
40 000 people going out there
you know like they were on a family
vacation
i always wondered what buddy rich would
have thought about that
praise your god goddamn it kid you go
out there with a sports coat on or you
don't go out on the bed stand at all
woman and jay
on a [ __ ]
loop
i can't get to sleep laying in bed on
medicine
oh jesus
um
shout out to all the people who are
getting all [ __ ] upset over here
about the uh the international news
that's going on in the news
internationally
it just blows my [ __ ] mind the amount
of people that are watching the footage
of that horrible [ __ ] that's happening
in in the ukraine
you know what i mean and like they don't
they can't put two and two together and
be like oh is this what invading a
country looks like
wait have we ever done that
and if we did this is what it looked
like like people just
does somebody need to make a video like
you know when they do that thing like
celebrities they're just like us they do
their dry cleaning
russia they're just like us
[Music]
um
uh you know i always have this fantasy
that everybody around the world just
quits the military
on the same day at the same moment just
like yeah we're not doing this anymore
all right if you got a problem with that
guy over there okay the leader of that
country you go fight him
you go over there you put your penny
loafers on
and you're the little [ __ ] johnny
appleseed backpack and you go over there
and you go fight that guy
i mean
i don't know and then people sit there
and they watch the goddamn videos
just from like one side
like it's it's like you know it's like
feminist oh jesus bill where the [ __ ]
you going i don't know i didn't get any
sleep last night don't listen to me
you know when they just male toxicity it
shouldn't they just they don't see
themselves in it
they don't see what they did to make the
guy in their life toxic that's what i'm
trying to say it's your fault ladies no
they don't see
they don't see what they do
you actually think you know
real feminists do though
you know you haven't there's nothing
cooler than a cool feminist like my
wife's a cool feminist
if i make a decent point
you know about the broads there she'll
be like all right
all right you got me on that but don't
and then that makes me be like okay let
me hear you no i can hear you now
what is the point of this bill i don't
know what the point of this is the point
is i didn't get any [ __ ] sleep last
night
and i'm comparing invading countries to
feminist rhetoric that's exactly what
i'm doing
all right it was a bad weekend people i
had a bad
i had one great part of the weekend i
went to a birthday party at chuck e
cheese
i'd never been to that
place holy [ __ ]
i'll tell you right now if you if you've
never been
like
if you've never been to america
and you only have two hours to be here
and you want to get a feel for what this
country has to offer you got to go to
chuck e cheese
you know
pizza
soda
video games
that's it
some [ __ ] dude walking around in a
mouse outfit dancing to music i mean it
was [ __ ] it was amazing
i i thought i was going to go there and
i was going to come out of there like
exhausted and all that you know chasing
the kids around there i had a blast
parents were having a good time were
eating pizza right
and then they had enough games there for
adults they had a [ __ ] motogp game
well you could race somebody else i was
racing my daughter she's on another
motorcycle i'm scrolling through seeing
if i can find andres davidsioso ducati
right
although he's riding for suzuki this
year i think i don't know it's starting
up soon
um they had a game where you know you're
throwing footballs through three
different circles
[ __ ] popping out if you hit that you
know
get 40 points
try to make the hall of fame release the
pro bowl if you played like [ __ ] it
called you a rookie like the game was
talking [ __ ] it was great
[ __ ] i like those old school games like
you just press a button and you're
firing like
torpedoes to try to sink ships
those are the games i like before it got
too involved you know like now people
just put like a virtual reality glass
glasses on and by time you're done
playing with the game you got to buy a
new flat screen tv
because you tried to dive through a
porthole you forgot you were in your
living room
that's like that's too much i think
right
woman and chase um
anyway yeah i have just a crazy weekend
been so busy haven't been able to
[ __ ] sleep i'm i'm joking about the
night quilt it's like i'm not doing the
night quilt thing i don't want to
[ __ ] do that because then all of a
sudden you're going to need the night
quilt to go to sleep right and then
you're hanging out out in front of a cvs
you know
panhandling for [ __ ] nickels
so you can go in there you know with a
handful of weight you know just change
and just slamming it down so you can get
the big gulp size of it
um
yeah i was talking to somebody
and they were saying like they were
going through some [ __ ]
and then they go you know whenever i'm
going through some [ __ ] i just like
google [ __ ] up [ __ ] on the internet
so i realized that my [ __ ] isn't that
bad and i was like oh all right little
perspective and they ended up showing me
this [ __ ]
clip of this poor guy
who got eaten by a shark down in [ __ ]
australia
unfortunately it was like blurred out
and i was just like i had to like shut
it off
i had to shut the [ __ ] thing i was
like oh it was one of my most horrifying
things i
it was blurred out but just knowing what
this poor person was going through
and
my buddy told me
that he watched the the [ __ ] unedited
version of it i'm like why the [ __ ]
would you do that he's like dude
dude it was [ __ ] up dude yeah yeah
what was it
i've never [ __ ] understood like
somebody blows their knee out in a
[ __ ] sporting event i can't even
handle that i don't understand how you
could [ __ ] watch
one arguably one of the biggest fears
people could have at least my generation
when jaws came out
you know and speaking of jaws
like i feel like all of these [ __ ]
vacation spots when there's a shark
attack act just like that douchebag
who didn't want to close the beaches
in jaws
what's he doing sitting up there he's
scaring people
right i noticed i started googling as i
always do because i am [ __ ] terrified
of the ocean and uh and it's kind of
funny because there's a lot of people
also who are terrified of flying
so when i express my fear
of uh the ocean
they then question well yeah but you fly
helicopters you're up there i mean
isn't that you know it's a fair point
you know what i mean but it's i don't
feel like it's nearly
maybe i'm just justifying maybe i'm
doing the sports fan thing
like rams and bengals fans after the
super bowl
where bengals fans were just like
you know all right you missed you know
whatever say like rams fans were going
well
they missed that call they missed that
call you know with the face mask so that
we deserved a makeup call
and it was just like yeah but at the end
of the game that's when they do it that
[ __ ] happened like the third play of the
[ __ ] second half
they had the whole third rest of the
third quarter and half of the fourth
quarter
to keep a drive alive they do it at the
[ __ ] end to hook you up
where if you score there's going to be
no time left for the bengals well that's
not a makeup call that goes a little
further right
and then bengal fans on the other side
i don't know
i don't know what the [ __ ] they i still
feel like they got [ __ ] they got
screwed on that one
they got screwed on that one um i don't
i i had a point in there just somehow i
lost the whole [ __ ] thing
but uh i did look up like shark attacks
you know because of the way i view it
like you know we're kind of fishing out
the ocean and we've already fished out
the ocean and they're they're dragging
these nets so deep they're pulling up
they're pulling up species of fish that
they they don't even have a price on it
at the market
okay you can go on youtube and look up
recipes for these fishes and there's no
recipes because in the history we've
never [ __ ] caught these goddamn
things
because they swim so deep so my theory
is that
since we fished out the [ __ ] ocean
that human beings have moved up on the
menu
where before we were sort of this weirdo
thing on the last [ __ ] page
and now we've moved up to like the
second course
and uh pretty soon we'll be in entre
and i don't mean andre as in the main
dish the way they say it in america i
mean in france well you're the appetizer
you're the first thing
first thing that they're going for
entree as an enter you're entering the
meal
um
anyway but one thing i've noticed with
all of these vacation
hot spots
is they all say the same [ __ ]
it's always reported in a rare
shark attack
look up shark attack and i'm telling you
the word that you're gonna keep seeing
is rare
a rare shark attack so i'm like okay
these shark attacks
are rare
right
like how they cook a steak when you ask
for medium rare it comes out rare most
people it's like that's not it's not
medium rare medium rare is a [ __ ]
lost art
i swear to god you go to a steakhouse
now and it's either rare medium medium
well and well nobody seems to be able to
do the [ __ ] medium rare anymore if
you ask for medium rare it's coming out
bloody and then you'd be like hey i'm
sorry man can you can you put this back
on for a little bit longer then it's
going to come back medium
and i always think that the cook's back
there having a hissy fit
how dare you question night i don't know
what's the the medium rare is
i mean how do you [ __ ] that up
a few backyard grillers i remember i
used to work on a [ __ ]
i used to work on a mesquite grill in a
[ __ ] restaurant that was rapidly
going out of business while i also was
still a bus boy and a dishwasher
as the restaurant went out of business i
just kept taking on more and more jobs
and they just kept giving me like 50
cents more an hour instead of paying me
to do two jobs i was such a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
like say i was making five bucks an hour
back then
it was probably even less than that
minimum wage back in the 80s to be a bus
boy
and then the grill chef was making seven
bucks an hour he quits i take over the
grill
now shouldn't i be making 12 an hour no
they gave me five like 75 an hour i'm
like boy oh boy
oh whole another 75 cents and then the
dishwasher quit and i did that too and
he was probably making like four bucks
an hour so right there i should have
been making like 16 an hour and instead
they were paying me like six dollars an
hour
i can't imagine what they've said about
me
like that's got to be the dumbest busboy
dishwasher mesquite griller all at the
same time [ __ ] person i've ever met
in my life
um but anyway i i
they taught me when i was making burgers
they were just like all right if you
want to know what
rare is
take your thumb and just touch it to
your index finger and then touch your
thumb meat
you know like if your thumb's a
drumstick the part that you would eat on
a drumstick you just touch it right
there and then touch the meat it should
feel like that you touch your middle
finger that's like more like uh you know
medium rare medium and then your uh ring
finger with your thumb
that's like medium well and then your
pinky that's well done
now great granted that also depends on
the thickness of the meat ladies
right
then you kind of got to go low and slow
with it or whatever but i mean i
remember learning that i've never i've
never really [ __ ] that up
unless it's been like a like uh what's
really hard is a filet mignon
you know what i mean i've never really
understood how to try to cook that thing
you know if somebody wants it medium
you know
what ends up happening is by the time
it's all gray there's no pink left like
the outside is like kind of [ __ ]
you know christ you cooked the [ __ ] out
of it
um anyway so they say that these shark
attacks are [ __ ] rare
so i started looking at the numbers now
i'm not trying to [ __ ] with any
country's uh tourism here
or is that it's known behind the closed
door horrorisms
horrorism right we got to get the [ __ ]
we got to get the [ __ ] coming in here
so the guys think they got a [ __ ]
chance
you know they're getting their dick
sucked down here okay this is this is
how they really talk before they [ __ ]
you know have clowns and balloons
in a cruise ship
commercial that they put together they
talk about [ __ ] and blow jobs that's
basically what it is and you know
not saying
that it's a requirement that the woman
goes to that island that that's how she
has to behave but it's more that the um
the hope
the belief more so beyond hope there's a
belief that you're gonna go down there
and this
is gonna happen and um
and why wouldn't they you know women
when women go
out of the country
they
feel like they're no longer being judged
right and they can kind of get you know
a little loose with it
this is what i've heard
i've heard like that as far as like
their number how many people you've
banged they don't count people outside
the country
they try to keep the number down
because of the double standard there's a
double standard
how come when a guy does it he's a
stutter if a woman does it he's a she's
a who
i just do a bit about that
well it all comes down to degree of
difficulty
you know
guys have to convince people to [ __ ]
them
that's why it's impressive you got laid
last night what did you say
right
i'm sorry
this podcast is just all over the
[ __ ] road um
yeah so they keep saying that i'm going
to get through this thought at some
point they keep saying that shark
attacks are rare
uh in a rare shark attack so i looked up
the caribbean or the caribbean
is it caribbean or caribbean tomato
tomato
bengals bangles
um
they said in the caribbean they average
20 to 30 a year that's not rare that's
like you know almost three a month
two to three a month that's not [ __ ]
rare
they never say come to the bahamas
and swim in waters where we average two
to three shark attacks
per month
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know most of them are just nibbles
i love when they say that like they go
like
they don't want to eat yet they're just
sort of curious
oh is that what it is
i i don't want a curious bite from a
shark
hey what happened to that section of
your leg it seems to be uh there's a
little void there on the back of your
thigh where your hamstring used to be
oh you know what tiger shark was uh you
know
he was just curious
i'll tell you they're they're
inquisitive little devils those those
[ __ ] sharks
there is no goddamn way
there is no
[ __ ] way until the fish come back
the fish come back at night
the fish come back at night until the
fish come back the fish go back
until the fish [ __ ] come back
and those goddamn sharks have something
to eat
i i am calling it right now
all right you want to bet the over on
shark attacks
australia says they average 20 a year
20 attacks a year
but then they they downgrade and they in
20 rare
okay let me ask you this if you did
heroin twice a year would you say your
heroin use was rare
listen
i only nod off like twice a month
do you
do you um
do you shoot drugs yes but only 20 to 30
times a year
i have to be honest with you though like
are you addicted
oh my god am i going to look that up are
you addicted if you do heroin 30 times a
year
be a [ __ ] great thing to say in rehab
how come how come all we do is talk
about the month where i did it
you know what about the 335 days where i
didn't do it hello
hello exactly
i gotta look that up
at what point
are you addicted
at what point will i [ __ ]
stop picking this recorder up and
setting it back down again on the floor
all right
while i look this up
enjoys tears for fears
um
how many
times a year
before you are
addicted
the science
of a
addiction
john hopkins johnny
johnny hopps
learn more about addiction how long does
it take to break the habit of addiction
all right let's see what we say uh this
is the wrong [ __ ]
it takes 21 days to break an addiction
the old belief that it took 21 days to
change habit has now been labeled a myth
yeah like the earth being round
according to psychologist
while it may take approximately 21 days
of conscious and consistent effort to
create a new habit it takes far longer
to break an existing habit
well then you know i bet a lot of people
who go to the beach go built 20 to 30
like millions of people go out of the
[ __ ]
right that's what they say
all right which i understand i do
understand that but like
you know
when what we're talking about is being
eaten alive
uh you know i still don't like those
percentages i'm just saying that you
know what i mean and a lot of you guys
who are like
[ __ ]
beach goers and anti-vaxxers
you know use the opposite thing when you
decided not to get vaccinated you'd be
like well [ __ ] there was somebody and
uh [ __ ] tupelo mississippi who got
the booster shot and all of a sudden
they [ __ ]
robbed a liquor store right you that
[ __ ] made sense to you
right it's all about crunching the
number maybe that's what it is it's just
crunching the number you don't want to
get the vaccine so you're just going to
focus on people that had a bad reaction
to it and then people that want the
vaccine and look at all the people that
didn't and the same thing with
beachgoers and i'm afraid of the ocean
so all i'm going to do is look at the
shark look at that
i learned something from you
and you learned something from me
um
so maybe it is
maybe that's the thing
how many people
go
to the
caribbean each year
caribbean destination received an
estimated 32 million
and so it's literally one in a million
1.3 million
verse okay how many people go to the
korea
caribbean each year versus how
many
get
bitten
by a shark
yearly worldwide shark you know what
nobody's gonna have these [ __ ]
nobody's gonna give me the stats that i
need you know why because they're afraid
of the results
um the isaf
is that literally the international
shark oh shark attack file
hey big boy what do you do for a living
i work for the isaf
is that a branch of the military
no
it goes beyond these borders sweetheart
it's the international shark attack file
that sounds exciting
um
the floor
the florida museum of natural history's
international shark attack file
investigated
137 alleged
shark human interactions worldwide in
2021
they're still calling him a legend you
[ __ ] show up you don't have a calf
anymore
got bitten by a shark or so you say
jesus christ how much money are sharks
the shark lobby throwing at [ __ ]
politicians
to get them to look the other way
even sharks are into paola
isaf confirmed 73 unprovoked shark
attack shark bites on humans and 39
provoked bikes
okay
unprovoked bites i think the second you
go in the in the ocean you're provoking
unprovoked bites are defined as
incidents in which a bite on a live
human
see look at
[Music]
look how they're already starting to
crunch these numbers and frame trying to
make a ball a strike a bite on a live
human as opposed to what
some mob hit that they would the big
[ __ ] who got thrown in the [ __ ]
ocean that one doesn't count
unprovoked oh my god how psyched were
they
when big [ __ ] got thrown in
they probably didn't appreciate that
with what they thought was a seal was
wearing a [ __ ] tracksuit and sneakers
um unprovoked bites are defined as
incidents in which a bite on a live
human occurs in the shark's natural
habitat
with no human provocation of the shark
do you see how many loopholes are in
that the shark's natural habitat is the
[ __ ] ocean
all right
i mean it's not [ __ ] walking down the
street like the old snl land shark [ __ ]
right
what is a shark's natural habitat oh
this is some slippery [ __ ] political
[ __ ] here
what is a shark's
quote natural
habitat here we go somebody else says
they are found in just about every kind
of ocean habitat including the deep sea
open sea
coral reefs and under the arctic ice
whenever the wherever they live sharks
play an important role in ocean
ecosystems especially the larger species
that are more scary to people
they put quote scary
um as if you're not really scared as if
it's your issue all right provoked bites
occur when a human initiates interaction
with the shark in some way these include
instant
instances when divers are bitten after
harassing or trying to touch sharks
bites on spear fishers bites on people
attempting to feed sharks bites
occurring while unhooking or removing a
shark from a fishnet and so forth
of the remaining 25 cases four involved
bites
to motorized or non-motorized marine
vessels boat bites
and one involves shark inflicted
post-mortem bites
scavenge oh like if you drowned oh i get
it five cases were regarded as doubtful
or incidents that did not likely involve
the shark
these included one case attributed to a
stingray
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
three attributed to bony fish don't they
all have bones and one to injury in one
injury and one to injury associated with
scraping against a rock
yeah that's something i would do i'd
scrape against a rock and i'd be like
sure
get everybody to go back to the beach
in a single case the nature of the
incident was unclear with the available
data an additional 14 cases could not be
confirmed as a shark human interaction
yeah
this seemed they kind of
i feel like they're sort of spinning the
numbers down
um
but anyway by all means if you enjoy the
beach don't listen to me if you enjoy
tears for fear don't listen to me
especially if you're a woman in chains
um
all right zip oh look who it is
everybody old zip
[Applause]
according to the latest research 90 of
employees planned to make enhancing the
employee experience a top priority in
2022
after all a happy workplace is the key
to attracting and keeping great
employees and if you need to add more
employees to your team they're zip
recruiter that was the shark version the
jaws version their matching technology
helps you find the right people for your
roles fast and right now you can try zip
for free free at ziprecruiter.com
zippercurry uses its powerful technology
to find and match the right candidates
up with your job then it proactively
presents these candidates to you you can
easily review these recommended
candidates
dude you know that [ __ ] shark that
killed that guy
in sydney australia that the news media
asked if they had found the shark yet
like how are you going to tell
i don't know
they got like [ __ ] helicopters flying
the helicopter can only go out so far
does the shark hang around the area
do they look do they do they do they use
zip
to find the [ __ ] shark you can easily
review these recommended candidates and
invite your top choices to apply for
your job which encourages them to apply
faster no wonder zip recruit is the
number one rated hiring site in the
united states based on g2 ratings zip
technology is so effective that four to
five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
find the right employees for your
workspace with ziprecruiter try it for
free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
that's ziprecruiter.com
b-u-r-r
ah [ __ ] i gotta i gotta wrap this
podcast up and i'm only like
37 minutes in bowling branch no one
wants to cut corners on what's important
and few things matter more than a good
night's rest oh my god i need this right
here bowling branches signature sheets
feel so soft and light you'll forget
you're not actually sleeping on a cloud
uh people for the re just for the record
if you tried to sleep on a cloud
all right
first of all you might be so high that
you can't breathe up there but you would
fall through it okay sorry i just want
to be that jerk who just brings up
reality
you actually think that you could
sleeple a cloud
i'm sorry and they're sustainably made
from uncompromising quality
from the field to the factory
jesus sounds pretty intense
you call this cotton
in your dream of comfortable in your
dream if you dream of comfortable sheets
at a price that won't keep you up all
night look no further than bowl and
branch i mean listen to that name it
sounds like a steak house a law firm
i mean that just sounds that sounds like
some old school stuff that you can
believe in bowling branch makes the
softest organic sheets on the market or
our name isn't bowling branch and they
get better with every wash
and comfort isn't their only standard
i'm going to order some
by the end of this [ __ ] read here the
signature hemmed sheets from bowl and
branch are a best seller for a reason
buttery soft lightweight organic cotton
in a classic satin weave for sheets that
get softer over time
i want some of these man i need a bowl
and branch signature sheets come in
seven beautiful colors in all sizes from
twin
up to california king
made to a higher standard 100 organic
cotton ethical production and thoughtful
attention to every detail experience the
best sheets you've ever you've felt ever
at
bowlingbranch.com get 15 off your first
set of sheets when you use the promo
code bur at checkout that's bowl and
branch
b r b-o-l-l-a-n-d
n c h dot com promo code burr all right
let's get through the reads as quick as
i can i'm unfortunately gonna have to
stop in ten minutes because uh
i'm getting picked up to go do some more
of this
stuff here for this this thing i'm
working on all right [ __ ] jawon howard
i defended juwan howard
last week i thought it was great um i
think what's wrong with the world right
now is there's so many people that need
a [ __ ] good slap but you can't
anymore because of cell phone cameras
and then the slap e gets gets money
and nobody asks well why did they slap
him so this person is trying to tell me
that john howard is is [ __ ] hey there
billy basketball juwan howard is the is
the [ __ ] if you don't want teams taking
timeouts while you're getting your ass
whipped then stop full court pressing
and take out all your starters
oh that's the other side of the story
oh so they were also on they were both
on their rag also if you're going to
punch someone then do it like a man and
don't mush their face with half a punch
like a [ __ ] no no no no that's the
difference between getting sued
like i think you can slap someone across
the face
and not get sued
but if you punch them they bruise
the great thing about a slap is by the
time the cops get there the person's
face isn't red anymore and he can just
be like i didn't i didn't touch him
underrated a nice [ __ ] slap
um this isn't you know i love a slap too
because a slap is like you don't even
think they're man a man and man enough
for a [ __ ] closed fist
so you slap them
the way men used to hit their wives when
it was legal
you know do you think when it was legal
they used to do it more often like
people who now wouldn't like
is the is it the fear of jail or the
knowledge that you shouldn't hit a woman
that's the question uh this isn't the
first time old juwan howard has had
problems with other coaches and it's
only his third in the conference well if
you're getting your ass kicked you're
still full court pressing with your
starters in there
that that is a [ __ ] move the guy is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's this asshole's
opinion anyway all right i like in the
end then you're like you might be wrong
thanks for the podcast and the comedy
love all of it well wishes to you and
the family all right
fair enough
all right but at the end of the day i
don't think as a five foot ten inch
human being you should be yelling at a
guy six foot eleven and not expect
somebody at least near you
to take a [ __ ] slap from across the
room all right robbery story
bellerica in the 90s
from a lady
i used to do stand-up at the bellerick
in 99s
99 restaurant in bel ricka in the 1990s
all right hey bill no need to insult
someone
you're about to tell a story all right
uh
let me set the scene for you yeah that's
it set the table for me i was in my
senior year of high school working at a
craft supply store in bel ricka
massachusetts in the 1990s
one of the last great decades there was
at least in my life
um
i was head of the cheerleading squad and
looked the part
in hindsight i would have targeted me
too
i like how you just basically said i was
a hot piece of ass and if i saw me i'd
take a shot too anyway we were closing
on a sunday
wait no no that's not you i was head of
the cheerleading squad and looked apart
and in hindsight i would have targeted
me too i forgot what this story was
about i immediately thought that some
guy came in and tried to look up your
[ __ ] cheerleader skirt like that's
how you went to work
i'm an idiot what you're saying is is
that you look like [ __ ] like oh golly
gee rah-rah sith boom-bah you didn't
look like you could defend yourself i'm
sorry
uh we were closing on a sunday when a
sketchy looking man walked in we didn't
get too many men in the craft store i
was the only one up front i was in the
middle of vacuuming up ribbon and pieces
of my soul from that miserable job
when i heard a man say hey i rolled my
eyes shut the vacuum off and spun around
with the big smile yes sir can i help
you
i said uh yeah can
i said uh yeah can you check me out
he responded whole he said you should
have said okay
oh no no i get what you say yes sir can
i help you i said
ah yeah can you check me out he
responded sorry
i i didn't read this right the
punctuation and capitalizations of
letters there freaked uh didn't freak me
out confuse me all right he responded
now yeah can you check me out holding a
bag of glitter it's the strangest thing
i've ever seen anyone randomly grab
sure come on over i said he followed me
to the cash register wonderful turning
your back to him as i was typing in the
code for the glitter he leaned in and
said look at me sweetheart i have a gun
in my pocket when you open up that
drawer you're going to give me all the
money in it and not say a word
i slit the glitter i set the glitter
down looked him dead in the eyes and
said
do you know how many times a day i open
this drawer and have to talk myself out
of taking all the money in it
wait
you said what
looked him dead in the eyes and said do
you know how many times a day i open
this drawer and have to talk myself out
of taking all the money
in it as i'm dealing
with little old ladies in their coupons
all day
shove the glitter up your ass i ain't
giving you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] said that
your job was so miserable that you
actually put your life on the line
the gear and she goes he looks so
confused for a minute then he just ran
out of the store
to bring life full circle i became a
substance abuse counselor in boston
after college bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed i walk into my first group
session
and this [ __ ] was sitting there
what are the [ __ ] chances i don't
know this story sounds pretty wild to me
this is like one of the coolest stories
ever or you're just [ __ ] with me a
decade later in several cities away here
he was again i never told him who i was
but i did confirm that he was who i
thought he was
life's wild
i mean what are the odds of that
happening is that as high as [ __ ] get
eaten by a [ __ ] shark if you go to
the caribbean
i keep saying the caribbean because i
love australia
um not that i don't love the caribbean
i just know i'm not gonna go there
because it's it's just too [ __ ] hot
um
that is one of the most epic [ __ ]
things ever if you really said that
i looked him dead in the eye
and said you know how many times a day i
open this drawer and have to talk myself
out of taking all the money in it as i'm
dealing with little old ladies in their
coupons all day shove that glitter up
your ass i ain't giving you [ __ ]
i really shouldn't read these stories
this is irresponsible because people are
going to [ __ ] you know somebody says
they got a gun i'm going to be like all
right you want to take arts and crafts
money
is this going to get you that house on
the water
um we dealer robbery
hey billy bong rip like people rob a
[ __ ]
arts and craft store because they're
trying to buy a house what a stupid
theory that was they robbing it because
they want money for drugs uh hey billy
bogrip
uh you've been asking listeners to send
in robbery stories so here is a good one
that had me in in that happened to me in
high school like many high schoolers i
made some money here and there through
selling weed to my friends oftentimes i
took referrals from people i trusted one
time my buddy referred me to someone i
didn't know
and being stupid i took him up on it
i started talking to this guy my friend
my friend referred to me
referred me to and he was sketchy out of
the gate wanting to only meet at night
and such again being stupid i took my
girlfriend wait a minute what the [ __ ]
happened
i was thinking about the fact that i ate
two cupcakes last night and why did i do
that why couldn't i stop at one
okay i made money here and there through
selling weed oftentimes i took referrals
from people i trusted one night my buddy
referred me to someone i didn't know and
being stupid i took him up okay
anyway i took my girlfriend at the time
to his neighborhood in a very bad part
of town as we were driving towards this
place we could see people following my
car throwing bottles and whatnot just a
bad vibe the guy told me to pull down
this dead end street and park my car
after waiting a minute or two we could
see this figure approaching my car from
the back left side he entered the back
left door and told and i told him where
the weed was
he grabbed the backpack i had
and put the weed in and started getting
out i said hey where's the cash right
then he pulled the gun out of his hoodie
and put it to the back my head said
count to 60 and back out
my girlfriend started counting
and we left
i was in such shock and it was about six
hundred dollars worth of weeds so yeah
it sucked balls my stupidest moment of
the whole story is that instead of
comforting my girlfriend back home i
started making food just to try to
distract from what had just happened
[ __ ] insane
anyways thanks for the comedy go [ __ ]
yourself yeah you had a traumatic
experience and you weren't ready to deal
with it all right i got one more here
wow
that's some feeling i don't ever want to
know the feeling of a [ __ ] gun to
your goddamn head
um a lady looking for advice say oh
billy freckle speckle
i'm a lady
listener since 2009 big fan of all your
work and loved you
in the recent uh dog movie yes go out
and go see the movie dog
it's uh
it's playing now at your local showcase
cinemas there
um
anyway i need some
advice from my husband this year we are
celebrating our 20th anniversary
together congratulations and i'm
struggling on what to get him we've been
together since high school and so
there's not much surprise left in our
relationship which is fine we're both
very happy and still in love but i'm
really not sure what the hell to get him
as a present i was thinking about doing
uh doing one of those
boudoir photo shoots that are growing in
popularity get your hair and makeup done
and basically pay a [ __ ] ton of money to
take sexy photos don't [ __ ] do that
have some [ __ ] creep keep the
negatives however do they even use film
anymore
however i'm thinking he'll look at the
pictures once and the album will get put
inside a cabinet for years i'm curious
what you think is a good gift or if nia
has ever purchased you something that
you absolutely loved
we don't have any kids so we typically
go out all the time and buy whatever we
want so it's really tough i have no clue
any help is appreciated thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself
um
i had the best christmas uh
i've had as an adult this past year
my wife bought me a little bose uh
speaker thing that synced up to my phone
and wherever i go i can just take this
thing with me it's like a little stereo
just cranks
my music i got the [ __ ] apple
headphones
and well i guess one other thing
yeah does he have like a hobby or
something like that if he has a hobby
just buy him the next level thing in his
hobby
um i would do something like that or
uh
you know then there's always the classic
you know uh take the guy out to dinner
and then blow him afterwards i mean
that's i mean that's a hundred percent
take him out to chuck e cheese
and [ __ ] blow him in the parking lot
like you're still in high school like
you did way back like the reason he ma
make him remember why he married you
you know and the same thing goes for
guys
make them make the ladies remember
why you married them take them to dairy
queen
and chow their box in the
[Music]
i'm [ __ ] with you that's not why they
married you
take it to some stupid [ __ ] store and
buy them another goddamn designer bag
that they don't need
that's why they married you and then go
run an errand after you're already out
that requires you to drive past the
house
as they tell you to swing by
can you swing by over here
i'm driving past the house that's not
swinging by all right that's the podcast
everybody
um
anyway i gotta go do this [ __ ] i'm
gonna be super busy over the next month
my podcasts are still gonna be coming
out you know uh
on you know on mondays i think
or maybe not i don't know with our shoot
schedule it's gonna be [ __ ] a little
crazy so uh i might have to be like
adjusting
when these things come out i will let
you know
how it's gonna work um as my weekends on
this shoot are going to be thursday and
friday
and we work the other five days so i
think
that i might have to uh
record the monday morning podcast on
like a friday so who cares i can still
do it i'll figure it out that's it go
[ __ ] yourselves and i'll uh i'll talk to
you on thursday i'll check in on you on
thursday